un café contemporain c'est en ces termes
que se présente le nouveau restaurant du
château de versailles aurait à sa tête
alain ducasse un rêve de longue date
pour ce chef étoilé passionné par le
domaine et son histoire c'est juste
l'histoire de france ce lieu
emblématique ailier il est simplement
magnifique et je vais essayer d'y
recevoir
les visiteurs de passage à paris en
particulier au château de versailles
pour qu'il garde un souvenir indélébile
du déjeuner ou du dîner qu'ils auront
fait ici dans un lieu extraordinaire
voilà je pense que c'est mon rôle
inaugurée le 13 septembre
l'établissement a été installé au
pavillon dufour entièrement rénové il
propose une carte authentique en accord
avec le territoire local ici on propose
une cuisine axée sur le produit très
alain ducasse
voilà des condiments avec des produits
de saison respect respect des cuissons
respect des produits nous sommes en
train de
voir avec le potager du roi justement
pour
éventuellement créer un partenariat pour
pouvoir
voilà acheter leurs produits sans turbo
à la vapeur suprême de pintade et salade
de homard compter entre 20 et 40 8 euros
pour un plat au déjeuner le château de
versailles accueille plus de 7 millions
de visiteurs par an sa fréquentation
avait baissé en 2015 après les attentats
l'ouverture de ce nouveau restaurant
pour elle a relancé